morning everyone children could be
facing a return to online lessons for
the first time since lockdown if
teachers go on strike in the next few
weeks the National Education Union will
reveal the results of their strike
ballot today of 300 000 teachers in
England and Wales
I take a look at the plans strike this
week starting with nurses RCN members
will walk out this Wednesday and
Thursday thing to do here is to keep an
eye on the color coding nurses in blue
another strike by ambulance staff is
expected next Monday
teachers in Scotland begin 16
consecutive school days of strikes today
16 with different areas of Scotland
being affected each day in pink or
should we say fuchsia in London bus
drivers are striking today Thursday and
two days next week as well over 40
routes will see disruption on Wednesday
thousands of environment agency staff in
unison will strike the first world
strike in the agency's 27 year history
that's the one in red for you there and
looking ahead to next month on the 1st
of February more than a hundred thousand
civil servants in the PCS Union will
walk out affecting more than a hundred
government departments
teacher strikes in parts of Scotland
also continue as our political
correspondent Rob Powell has this report
from 999 staff and nurses to teachers
and trains another working week brings
more disruption teachers in Scotland are
beginning a 16-day program of strikes
with schools in Glasgow and East Lothian
affected today education unions in
England and Wales are also due to
announce their ballot results with
action expected one East London head
says pay and conditions are making it
hard to fill posts there are many
subjects in our secondary school at the
moment were struggling to fill the
vacancies they teach the training
agencies have not managed to recruit in
certain core subjects and all that is as
a result of parent condition of teachers
in the classroom
ambulance reps will meet today as well
to discuss further strike dates after a
weekend that saw one health union accuse
the government of demonizing workers
about patient safety the standoff is
particularly bitter over the issue of
NHS pay but while summing governments
have concluded that a higher wage
settlement is now needed for health
workers the treasury is insisting that
all departments live within their
existing budgets
today we'll also see controversial new
laws debated here in the Commons that
would force unions in health transport
and education to provide a minimum level
of service on strike days what's
absolutely clear about is the complete
lack of detail
um you know what it states is that the
Secretary of State can Define minimum
service levels and that puts us in a
frankly terrible position
whereby these decisions can be made
after there's more optimism on the
trains with a new offer expected to be
made to workers this week rail unions
remain cautious though saying any deal
needs to be put down on paper before
progress can be made Rob pal Sky News in
Westminster
and at half past eight we'll talk to two
union bosses the Neu National Education
Union who are announcing that strike
ballot today and the head of the
Scottish teaching Union
now in other news for the black box of
the plane that crashed in Nepal has been
found as investigators try to work out
what caused the country's worst air
crash in 30 years 72 passengers and crew
were aboard the yeti Airlines flight
which was seen rolling sharply before it
came down Rhiannon Mills reports
saying unsure what to do as the plane
burns the yeti Airlines flight deep in
the Ravine below them
difficult to spot any signs of survivors
among the smoke
as the haze moves away the spread of the
wreckage is clearer
half on the hillside what was once a
window and a seat close to where crowds
were gathering
the rest of the fuselage lying in the
River Gorge underneath Nepal's prime
minister promising any help that's
needed
this was filmed by a passenger in those
final seconds what appears to be a
normal approach everything calm nothing
seems wrong
hard to watch the plane was also filmed
from the ground close to pokeret airport
you can see the aircraft rolling sharply
on its side before it disappears yeah
on board four crew and 68 passengers
including 15 from overseas
foreign
the focus now is on the 15 year old ATR
72 aircraft and its crew as they
determine the factors that led to the
country's worst air crash in 30 years
Rhiannon Mills Sky News
well the black box as I said has been
found Neville standing by for us um that
will obviously have more clues for us
Neville what do we know so far about
what tragically happened yesterday
well now questions are being raised
about about the crash because yesterday
when it when the plane crashed the
weather was quite clear it was the Sun
was shining there was no Fogo or or any
sort of winter effects on on poker at
that point of time there are questions
also being raised why the poker
International Airport was pushed by the
government to to open uh its airstrip
also why the pilot had requested to land
from a different uh runaway rather from
the western side of of the strip rather
than the assigned one to him now
Nepal does have uh doesn't have a very
good track record in terms of air safety
or since 2000 over 350 people have died
in aircraft and helicopter crashes
across the country the European Union in
2013 has has put a blanket ban on
Netflix
airlines are coming into the airspace of
the union and and we've seen a boom in
the aircraft airline industry in Nepal
which many are questioning or
questioning the concerns of a compromise
to safety regulations in the country but
now that the investigations are taking
place the Prime Minister prachanda has
given a 45-day deadline to this
five-member group committee to
investigate into the causes we'll have
to wait and see what were the real
causes of this crash okay for now and I
will thank you
now also this morning a man has been
arrested following a shooting
that's outside of church near London's
Houston Station over the weekend joining
us now is uh Iva
um a man arrested at hyper what more
doing now good morning
good morning Kay yes so the 22 year old
is now in custody being held on
suspicion of attempted murder after
being arrested yesterday afternoon
around 4pm in Barnet in North London
that's around four five miles from here
and police say the arrest was made after
a car was stopped it's the first arrest
that's been made in connection with this
shooting outside this church here in
North London right next to Houston
Station the back of the station is just
around 30 meters to my left here
meanwhile of course those who are caught
up in this shooting remain in hospital
the youngest victim is still fighting
for her life police say a seven-year-old
girl remains in a stable but
life-threatening condition for women are
still in hospital including a 48 year
old who police say has suffered
potentially life-changing injuries while
a 12 year old girl who suffered leg
injuries police say is expected to make
a full recovery the shooting happened
here at on Saturday afternoon around 1
30. the mourners had been at a memorial
service inside the church for a young
woman and her mother had then come
outside when police believe the gunman
opened fire with a shotgun from a car
and after making this arrest they are
still appealing for anyone with any
information to come forward especially
anyone who witnessed this shooting okay
thank you
taking the front pages of the papers for
you this morning the teacher's strikes
are on the front of the eye with
warnings that students face a return to
online lessons
the guardian Fury over PM's bid to hand
police sweeping powers to Halt protests
reads the guardian as Rishi sunak plans
for a public order Crackdown
the times leads with the crisis facing
the NHS their headline two in three
voters think NHS offers bad service
call this a cure for NHS so care reads
the front of the mail as health experts
hit out at Labor's plan to let patients
refer themselves for treatment without
seeing a GP
and the telegraph reports on the arrest
of a man in his 60s on suspicion of a
terror offense after traces of uranium
were found in a cargo package at
Heathrow Airport
some of today's other headlines for you
this morning on the breakfast show and
man in his 60s arrested on suspicion of
a terror offense after traces of uranium
were found in a cargo package at
Heathrow police say they arrested the
man in Cheshire on Saturday he was later
released on bail border Force officers
discovered the radioactive substance
with a shipment of scrap metal
Jamaican authorities have seized an
estimated 74 million pounds worth of
cocaine in one of the biggest drug busts
ever in the country officials discovered
the shipment hidden inside a cargo ship
at the Port of Kingston Jamaica has long
been used as a hub by transnational
criminal organizations to move weapons
and drugs including sending cocaine to
North America and also to Europe
a walk has been airlifted to hospital
with multiple injuries after he was
swept over a waterfall in Dumfries and
Galloway a rescue operation was launched
after the man lost his footing and fell
into the water near moffatt the current
took him over one over one 10 to 15
meter high waterfall but he narrowly
avoided a 60 a 60 6-0 meter drop
police will get more powers to Clump
down on protest by shutting them down
before they start causing disruption the
government is tabling an amendment to
its public order Bill to allow police to
intervene in long-running campaigns
including the likes of Extinction
rebellion and just stop oil let's get
more from Amanda who's standing by for
us um so tell us more about this Amanda
when does it come into place and who
might it impact
yes so this is the public order bill
which is currently been looked at by the
house of laws the government just
introducing a new Amendment which will
give the police more power to crack down
on what the government's describing as
new Guerrilla tactics used by campaign
groups like just stop oil or Extinction
Rebellion things like slow walking
protests which will disrupt traffic in
City centers or blocking roads in other
ways now controversially the change
means that the police don't need to wait
for protests to actually begin if
they're deemed to be seriously
disruptive before actually stepping in
and shutting them down now the
governments say they're acting on
requests from the police for greater
legal Clarity the prime minister in some
comments released around this
announcement has said it's a fundamental
right for that people have to be able to
protest but it also needs to be balanced
by the right for ordinary people to go
about their day-to-day lives without
facing disruption perhaps unsurprisingly
campaign groups have reacted with
absolute outrage and human rights
organizations like Liberty say it's an
attack on the rights to protest and
saying it effectively gives the police a
blank check to actually shut down
dissent before it even happens now labor
say they believe that the police already
have all the powers they need to tackle
dangerous protests and this does come
after new laws were introduced just last
year which tightened the rules around
protesting including things like
allowing the police to set noise
restrictions for protests for example
now the police themselves have welcomed
this they say it's for Parliament to set
out what the law should be on this
arguing that they're facing many
long-running legal disputes and when
they're trying to carry out their duties
policing protests but it certainly looks
like quite a provocative move from a
government already
taking on the unions with their
anti-strike legislation this really does
seem to be a move which is certainly
firing up their core voters and enraging
their opponents okay Amanda thank you
no let's talk about the weather should
we looks like there's a cold snap on the
way temperatures are expected to fall as
low as minus 10 degrees Celsius wow and
the Met Office is warning this could
cause travel disruption today the drop
in temperature comes after widespread
flooding which has left big parts of the
country submerged this last week
looking at that in a bit more detail the
Met Office issued a yellow warning
across many parts of the UK for snow and
ice
let's get more should we step standing
by for us this morning um hi Steph how
bad is it going to be good morning
hello there yes well we do have a fair
amount of snow in Scotland that's where
we're going to see the majority of the
snow showers further south where we saw
those beautiful snowy pictures we have
an ice warning in force there that's
over parts of Northern Ireland the north
of Ireland also across into North Wales
Northern England and the Northern parts
of the Midlands that's where there's a
lot of ice around at the moment because
we've had so many showers and then the
southeast corner here we've had a lot of
wet weather too there's some very heavy
downpours a bit of that is turning a
little bit wintry we're seeing some
sleet we're seeing a little bit of snow
but that's moving away and I think by
lunchtime that largely should have
cleared away and then it'll be quite a
nice day k for many places many places
will see some sunshine we'll have a few
showers here and there
um but it will be cold as you said
instead of water will rain
will be in parts of Scotland we lost you
for just a second there we've got the
gist of what you were telling us though
have we got another question for her are
we just not going to risk it okay we
won't but I do be very careful if you
were driving driving in this morning
there's a lot of standing water on the
roads just be really really careful when
you're driving now a British woman has
died after being caught in an avalanche
near Mont Blanc
the 45 year old was hiking with two
other people when the Avalanche hit a
French search and rescue unit airlifted
her to chamonix but was unable to revive
her her death is the fourth in the
French Alps in the past week alone
and with parts of the world experiencing
extreme weather conditions let's have a
look at the impact of climate change on
the planet here we go this is our
um dashboard yep there it is at no no
coal at all again as you can see uh
being used Renewables up to 52 and a
half percent that's what we like to see
isn't it and this is the temperature
um since uh 1880
um industrial revolution of course and
this is the CO2 emissions in millions of
tons importing 3.7 of our energy as we
speak those are real-time numbers
changing absolutely all the time
meantime heavy snow has fallen in parts
of Iran's Capital Tehran have a look at
these pictures roads were blocked and
flights halted as the city struggled
against freezing conditions and thick
fog conditions in some areas were so bad
that schools were forced to turn to
online teaching several museums and
historical sites were also closed to
conserve energy as the country struggles
against a shortage of natural gas
down to -10 in places here in the UK
today so if you are going out make sure
you take your big coat with you now the
Football Association has condemned an
incident involving Arsenal's Aaron
ramsdale after a spectator tried to kick
the goalkeeper in his back following the
team's two-nil win over local Rivals
Tottenham the fans seemed to jump onto
an advertising hoarding behind the
Arsenal girl before appearing to aim a
kick at the goalies back
ramsdale addressed the incident after
the match
the Spurs funds were giving me some
throughout the second half
I'll give them some back
um which so that the few people who I
did do it to were was probably well
greeted
um you know sportsmanship like and then
a fan tried to where I jumped over and
uh give me a little punch in the back so
um yeah that's what happened and uh it's
a shame because it's just a game of
football at the end of the day
well in a statement the fa said we
strongly condemned the incident
involving a spectator that followed
today's Premier League fixture between
Tottenham Hotspur and Arsenal this is
wholly unacceptable behavior and we will
work together with the police the
relevant authorities and the clubs to
ensure the appropriate action is taken
at least 35 people have reportedly died
after an apparent block was hit by a
missile attack in the Ukrainian city of
denipro on Saturday emergency workers
searched the rubble for survivors
dismantling dangerous parts of the
building which had been home to almost 2
000 people the city's mayor says the
chances of saving people now are minimal
meantime Belarus so to start Air Force
drills with Russia they say the exercise
is purely defensive and is to prepare
for possible combat missions the move
comes as concern grows that Moscow is
pushing Minsk to join the war in Ukraine
the defense secretary Ben Wallace is set
to make a statement in the House of
Commons today on the UK's latest
decision to send tanks to Ukraine
what's going to talk to our guests about
Ben Barry former director of British
Army staff UK Ministry of Defense hello
to you thanks for joining us on the
program this morning we saw that
absolute tragedy uh over the weekend
when an apartment block with 2 000
people inside was targeted uh by the
Russians what more do we know
well I think we know that most of them
actually got out but sadly there's been
some casualties and this is all part of
Russia's campaign to attack Ukrainian
civilian infrastructure power Heating
and uh the role the railways some of the
cruise missiles they're firing are
pretty accurate but at the moment they
seem to be firing a lot less accurate
ballistic missiles and obviously Naval
cruise missiles so it isn't surprising
I'm afraid
Callum attacks like this be described as
war crimes
well that's that's not an easy question
to Art to answer if they're actually
aimed at the
um a military Target
and they've gone off course that's
probably not a war crime but if they've
actually been deliberately aimed at the
Ukrainian civil population for example
if it were deliberately aimed at that
apartment block there would be a case to
answer for a war crime
talk to me more generally than if you
would please sir about um Vladimir Putin
saying his special military operation
I'm quoting him directly is developing
within the framework of the plan does
that mean
The Tide is changing in this war
well the tides changed several times it
changed in
spring when the Russians failed to
attack Kiev and withdrew from it turning
their main effort to the dombas it's
changed the game with the successful
Ukrainian counter-offensive to kharkiv
and more recently with the
counter-offensive at Curson it seems at
the moment that Russia just doesn't have
the offensive combat power on the ground
to be able to recapture substantive
territory hence much of the front lines
turning into attrition rather like a
first World War battlefield
you talked about
um how he's changed his top commander on
the ground several times
um done that again over the last week or
so every time that happens we seem to
see even bloodier more deadly attacks do
you think that is
um each of them trying to prove that
they are more uh successful at trying to
win this war than the previous one
well that may well be the case k
um of course the the previous Commander
remains in the chain of command but
General garasimov who's the overall
Russian forces Chief has now taken
charge of the whole operation whether
though he can think of any new strategic
gambits that will unlock the battlefield
that's a difficult question to uh to
answer because of course the War Began
badly with considerable overall over
optimism displayed by Russia at a high
level of strategic and Military
incompetence whether he can make the
Russian forces much more incompetent
much more competent I should say is an
open question I think who's winning this
war at the moment
well yes they they still seem to have a
difficulty properly coordinating
combined arms for example even with the
addition of the the Wagner private
military company they're finding it very
difficult to concentrate sufficient
Force at a decisive point to break
through whereas on the other hand
Ukraine's fighting a strong defensive
battle and continuing to use its U.S
supplied High Mars rocket launchers and
other Western weapons as well as its
Special Forces and partisans to attack
Russian positions throughout their depth
so the chances of a Russian breakthrough
in the near future I think are pretty
low
including the promise of uh 14
um Challenger 2 tanks from the British
government are going to hear more on
that from the defense secretary in the
House of Commons later on today uh we're
speaking to the Lord done it last week
he says that's nowhere near enough what
do you think
well Ukraine's been very clear it said
it wants a minimum of 300 modern Western
tanks uh 14 British tanks and about a
dozen Polish tanks that polish has
Poland has in principle said it's
delivered is only a small proportion of
that that's two companies of tanks at
most whereas what Poland's asking for is
about six battalions worth of tax now
there are a lot of modern Western tanks
in Europe there's 2 000 odd leopard two
tanks which is the sort that Poland's
supplying and it ought to be not too
difficult for European NATO Nations that
have leopard too to club together to
find about 400 leopard tanks
there's an issue though isn't there with
these leopard tanks perhaps you could
explain that um to us it's a German
license and so there's a sticking point
yes they're German built and under the
terms in which they were sold to the
country's concern Germany has a veto on
them being sold to a third party now
Germany of course is a nation that has a
degree of institutional pacifism built
into its Constitution and in the past
it's refused to supply weapons to an
active theater theater of war although
Chancellor Schultz shortly after the War
Began in his speech saying that Germany
was at a zeitant wender a turning point
uh implied that Germany would become
much more
um assertive in exporting weapons to
Ukraine they have of course exported
weapons from anti-tank weapons to the
recent declaration Declaration of Nevada
battalion's worth of martyr infantry
fighting vehicles but there still seems
to be a degree of political and
institutional reluctance in Germany but
we will see shortly there's to be a NATO
um Nation Summit of the contact group
with net with Ukraine including all the
nations uh Beyond NATO and that's to
coordinate uh arms and equipment
supplies and deliveries to Ukraine and
it may be that Poland and the UK have
both acted in a way to encourage Germany
to remove the restrictions on the
exports of lepid 2 tax sure but to that
end Christine unbrecht I think I'm right
in saying the defense minister is
basically on her last legs when it comes
to her political position and there's a
lot of criticism internally uh for her
lack of action what sort of challenges
do you think that that political
disharmony in Germany what sort of
challenges do you think that could play
out in the battlefield in Ukraine
well if Germany uh makes difficulties
about this um approach to sending
leopard two tanks to
um Ukraine Ukraine will have less combat
less combat power uh than it would like
we need to be clear that the reason
Ukraine said it wants 300 tanks and six
or seven hundred infantry fighting
Vehicles as well as another 500
additional howitzers is so it can build
up heavy armored or mechanized
formations to mount a strategic
counter-offensive this year to evict
Russia from Ukraine if if no one
supplies more than the current
25 odd modern Western tanks that the
British and the Pope the polls have
declared Ukraine is going to find that a
lot more difficult
coming up we're going to be speaking in
more detail about the Scotland gender
Bill what is Rishi sunat gonna do about
that time is running out for him to
block it if that's his plan uh chatting
about that uh in just a moment or two
before that though the Australian Open
kicked off overnight with a familiar
face returning to Melbourne
yeah
received an adoring welcome on his first
public return to the Australian Open he
played a practice match ahead of the
tournament against the Maverick
Australian Nick kiriagos I always
pronounced his name wrong speaking on
court the Serbian who was deported
before last year's tournament due to his
covid-19 vaccination state has said I
feel a bit emotional I was looking
forward to coming back to this court he
starts his run in Melbourne tomorrow
against the Spaniard Roberto baina uh
also check out these pictures today
some of the ones that caught our eye
this is hello good morning remember it's
Blue Monday look at these little guys
they are just a couple of the record
number of seals that have been spotted
on a five mile stretch of coast in
Norfolk a total of
3796 Steel pups have been born so far
this winter while
1169 adults have been spotted by
volunteer who counts them and how do
they know if they're not double Counting
there you go
um 3796.
um half of the world's population of
gray seals live around the British
Coastline and places like horsey in
Norfolk are important breeding areas is
is what until that's a great shot as
well uh now the deadline for the prime
minister is she soon act to decide
whether to block Scotland's gender laws
will arrive this Wednesday the bill
would allow trans people to obtain a
gender recognition certificate without
the need for medical diagnosis
joined Now by campaigner Ellie gomisol
who is president of the national Union
of students in Scotland hello to you
it's good to see you thanks very much
indeed for joining us on the program
this morning uh subject very close
um to your heart tell us about your
journey through transitioning
well I came out as trans when I was 18
and I was about five years ago now I'm
23 now I had a really positive
experience
um all of my friends and family were
really really supportive
um I have to admit though I often joke
that the hardest thing about being trans
is the admin and and I think there's a
lot of Truth to that it's been one of
the the biggest barriers one of the
biggest hurdles uh for me
um I've been able to update things like
my passport my driving license
Etc to reflect my my name and my my
gender and the one thing that I've not
been able to do is update my birth
certificate and and that's because that
requires one of these gender recognition
certificates
um in order to do that that's all the
gender recognition certificate does
actually it allows you to update your
birth certificate and that means that if
you're getting married
um you can make sure that the marriage
is being recorded with you and you're
correct gender and means also that if
you pass away and that you can have
dignity in death by ensuring that the
death certificate is recorded correctly
now I've been not I've not been able to
to get that certificate and because I've
been on the waiting list for the NHS
gender identity clinics for that medical
diagnosis uh for coming up for five
years now I've not had an initial
appointment yet I'm still waiting I
don't know when that's going to be and
that means that under the current
process if I wanted to get that gender
recognition certificate to update my
birth certificate I would have to pay
for a private psychiatric assessment I
mean that costs hundreds of pounds on
top of all of the other costs related to
Gathering all of the the you know other
documents that they ask you to submit to
this sort of panel of so-called experts
who will never actually meet you to
determine whether you're man enough or
woman enough to update your birth
certificate and so that's been a real
barrier to me and so I was really really
excited and really happy that the the
the the Bell uh in Scotland that you
know we've been campaigning on for so so
long uh finally passed back in December
to make that process just a little bit
easier
can you when you are 16 years old
know that
this sort of decision that will change
your life forever is the right one
I think he absolutely can I mean I
certainly did I didn't come out until I
was 18. uh but I think I always knew
that I was trans and actually there's so
many uh young trans kids uh who've
transitioned you know some of them at
Primary School they've lived you know
the vast majority of their lives by the
time that they're 16 and that their new
gender
um and I think what's really important
when we're talking about this particular
bill is that all it is is about updating
your birth certificate that's all the
gender recognition certificate does
we're not talking about Medical
Treatments here we're not talking about
anything else we're talking about a
piece of paper which you know worst case
scenario if you know years later down
the line actually realize you know what
that wasn't right for me and you know
that that's not gonna change your entire
life if you need to change that back so
we are just talking about a bit of paper
here I think when we're talking about 16
17 year olds in particular I mean right
now in Scotland 16 year olds can vote in
Scottish elections can get married and
you can have a child you can join the
Army I think you know a lot of those
last couple of ones knew that that's a
much bigger impact on your life uh than
you know updating the the gender that's
marked on your birth certificate so I
think that not only is 16 young enough I
think that actually in the cases where
you know kids have been living in their
current gender for for almost their
entire lives at some point the majority
of their their childhoods actually I
think that the bill doesn't go far
enough and there does need to be
provision in the future for for younger
people to be able to with the support
you're in the right guidance and advice
be able to update uh you know their
birth certificates to get that gender
recognition certificate as well because
if you're a trans young person who's
been you know at school a lot of maybe
the kids are at high school if you
transition to primary school don't even
know that you're trans and then maybe
you're going to college or university
for the first time or getting your first
job you don't have any other forms of ID
and having to present that that birth
certificate that has the wrong name and
gender on it I think can be really
difficult and stigmatizing for for that
young person do you feel that given that
you know you're an expert on this matter
do you feel that you could put a number
on that age limit
well I I think that uh you know it's
something that that needs to be looked
at in more detail
um I think you know I I couldn't say
because you know I wasn't a kid myself
when I did uh come out exactly what that
age should be but I think that that you
know a lot of uh campaigners are talking
about you know sort of uh you know 10 uh
that sort of age
um but you know I think that the point
is is that we've not looked into this
enough about you know kids who are under
16 but we have talked for a very very
long time about 16 17 year olds in
Scotland I mean this discussion has been
going on for about six seven years now
uh since the the leaders of all of the
the parties in the Scottish Parliament
including the conservative party uh
first committed to these reforms so I
think that that we've had so many years
of consultation and talking about this
issue that that I think that we have you
know reached a solid conclusion here on
16 17 year old and we need to have more
discussions about younger people than
that to make sure that those those
people in the future are able to access
gender recognition certificates as well
as you know secure stama does not agree
with you he thinks that 16 is too young
for a young person to decide on
paperwork when it relates to their
gender and we know that the British
government also has concerns about the
bureaucracy of having different roles in
Scotland than for the rest of the union
and could in fact as a result block this
bill what would you say to the Prime
Minister this morning
or I would say look at the Belt look at
what it actually does look at where it
actually changes uh the the law and I
think when we've been talking about this
bill and in particular uh the lines that
have been coming from the UK government
all relate uh to the equality act the
equality act 2010
um which is the the law that you know
puts into place uh you know
anti-discrimination uh measures Etc
um it's the law that currently means
that you know trans people are able to
to access spaces for instance that match
the gender that we are rather than the
sex that we were assigned at Birth
um and I think that that you know all of
these conversations don't actually
relate to the really simple process of
updating your birth certificate which is
what this uh what this bill actually
does I I think that that you know we've
ended up getting into all of these
conversations about different Provisions
that the bill doesn't actually change so
what I'd say to both the Prime Minister
and to to Kia stama is look at what the
bill actually does and listen to the
people who have been looking at this for
years particularly to cure stamina I
mean you know the Scottish labor party
fully supported these reforms Mark
Drakeford the first minister of Wales
has also said that you know if Wales had
the same Powers as Scotland then this
would be something that the Welsh
government should be looking at as well
and you know in the conservatives
Theresa May has supported these reforms
and a number of Scottish conservative
msps also voted for the Bell back in
December so I say listen to the people
who have been working on this for years
look at the legislation look at what it
does and doesn't do and I think that
once you've done that the facts are
really simple yeah I mean I'm not sure
that it's completely correct to say that
it was fully supported by the a labor
party in Scotland it wasn't fully
supported by the SNP as well really if I
could quote Joanna Cherry to you from
the SMP not at all happy about women's
safety and what may happen as a result
of this bill
she says the bill will allow any man to
declare himself a woman and to gain the
legal status of woman for all or most
purposes after three months of living as
a woman what it means to live as a woman
is also left undefined and some using
that as an example of
previously being recognized as a man now
being recognized as a woman and being
potentially in a woman's jail
well I think there's a lot of things to
to unpack here first of all I think that
it's right that we don't have a
state-defined definition
um of what Womanhood means I think that
would be really dangerous not just for
Trans people but for for women across
the country
um if there was a strict set of
guidelines as to what it meant to to be
a woman that would be really worrying
when it comes to things like jails again
that's something that's covered under
the equality act 2010 this bill doesn't
change that and if you actually look at
again the equality act 2010 if you look
at section uh sorry paragraph 28 of the
equality act there's a specific section
in there which talks about when there is
a legal needs to still be able to
discriminate so that means that when
we're talking about things like jail for
instance you know if there was a genuine
threat uh for example for someone going
to say a women's prison
um then under the equality act that can
still be broken and that's regardless of
whether you've got a gender recognition
certificate or not it doesn't come into
it so I I think that when we're then
talking about uh you know whether or not
a man would be able to to fraudulently
claim that he was a woman and get a
gender recognition certificate I'd ask
well why on Earth would a predatory man
do that why would they go through that
process of getting a piece of paper that
allows them to update their birth
certificate that doesn't change their
access to things like Single Sex spaces
for instance all it does is it means
that you know the birth certificate now
says that they're a woman if they were
to get married they'd be recorded as a
bride and their death certificate would
say that they were a woman and I don't
see any reason why any predatory man
would see that as as a bonus or a way to
to access uh you know being being a
predator okay
um eloquently put Ellie it's good to
talk to you thanks for taking the time
this morning I appreciate it thank you
so what is the British government going
to do today we heard securma yesterday
saying that he was not uh content with
16 year olds making that life decision
um tomorrow's here good morning good
morning Kate what's the option well it
sounds as if they may well choose to
block this law passed by the Scottish
government just before Christmas and
what they described as a breakthrough
moment for equality but what happens
when the Scottish government passes a
law you've got four weeks for the
Westminster government to stop it
becoming law now that power has never
been used before since the evolution in
19 in the late 1990s so this is a big
moment not just for gender politics but
also Evolution as well well Rishi sunaka
said he has concerns about it not just
about
um the access to Single Sex spaces which
is something that other cabinet
ministers have spoken about but about
whether it puts people in Scotland in a
different legal category to England
whether it conflicts with equalities
laws because if someone in Scotland is
allowed to change their gender legally
without the debt without this gender
dysphoria medical diagnosis without
living in their acquired gender for two
years only for three months and then it
applies also to 16 and 17 year olds
that's probably the most controversial
bit than if someone from Scotland with
that new legal status came to England
could they access services that they
wouldn't be able to would you create and
what's been described as gender tourism
where people go to Scotland to acquire
that status and then come back again is
there a problem with how it affects the
rest of the UK where this does not apply
so the government say no decision has
been made and they're looking at the
legal advice about it but a decision
could come as soon as today and I think
all the indications are that Rishi sunak
may choose to go ahead and block it
based on that legal advice which would
of course infuriate Scottish politicians
and find out about that and indeed the
teachers strike a bit later on today
tomorrow for now thanks so much indeed
something else I want to talk to you
about this morning the government and
having announced they're no longer
supporting small businesses through the
energy bill relief program the scheme is
designed to support businesses and
public sector organizations such as
schools and hospitals by providing a
discount on wholesale gas and
electricity prices the Federation of
small businesses have said this is a
huge disappointment joining us now is
Tina McKenzie policy chair at the
Federation of small businesses hi Tina
good to see you this morning thanks for
joining us what are you most worried
about
we're really concerned about the Amanda
small farms across the country that
aren't going to be able to cope with the
huge increases they're going to see when
the the current scheme is abandoned in
April and there the government are
putting in a new scheme but it's really
not going to help small businesses very
much and therefore we're concerned about
small businesses either closing or
having to downsize even more than some
of them already have
so what support was this scheme offering
previously
so this man this scheme currently
offered businesses small and large
actually a cap on their energy costs as
we've seen due to the Ukraine war
um that energy prices just skyrocketed
and most businesses wouldn't have been
able to survive
um certainly a lot of businesses we see
from our reports do not have the case
flows that they previously had at Cash
reserves before covid therefore put them
in a very vulnerable position the
government acknowledged this acknowledge
we were in an unusual situation with
these bills that were just not not
payable by especially by small
businesses and therefore put in a cap on
on the amount of electricity bill and
gas bill that you may have per kilowatt
hour so what they've decided to do is to
gamble nigh that because wholesale gas
prices are coming down to gamble now and
get rid of the scheme completely and
bringing in bringing a kind of a new
scheme but really doesn't offer much at
all offers pennies to businesses and
we're quite concerned about the fact
that the government are gambling uh with
the energy Market assuming that
businesses can handle the the flux and
and the the fact that they don't know
what's going to happen with their energy
prices
well thanks very much indeed team let's
bring in Abdul maheed uh he runs the
post office and uh kitchen and is with
us now hi good to see what sort of
impact will this have on your business
good morning
good morning
excuse me
um the cap helped yeah I helped us
budget how much uh costs were and and
then we could manage the the overall
cost to the business but by removing the
cap we're in free fall uh um open to the
fluctuations of the energy prices so for
me personally I'm going to see my my
energy rise uh by 1500 pounds a month
when this cap is removed so that's about
18 000 a year straight off my bottom
line so it has a serious impact in my
business
um like I said impact say how we manage
the store Staffing and ultimately how we
serve the community
so what sort of appeal would you make to
the government this morning
I think we need some sort of certainty I
think by removing the cap the cat give
is that certainty and that allowed us to
to do our budgets and our plans based on
on that figure but by removing the cap
we were basically put in the hands of
the energy providers and and there's
huge fluctuations and many retailers are
in contracts uh where and now we'll see
a huge rise and the prices and and these
places cannot be passed on through
increased prices to the customers
because we're in a competitive market
and and the money has to be found
somewhere either through you know
personal sacrifices or Staffing but
everything that we do or plan to do to
to save money will impact the business
which ultimately you know your inner
vicious spiral down into to you know
your viability overall okay well I'm
sorry to hear the impact that it's
having on you hopefully the government
will be listening this morning and
listen to what you have to say thank you
for taking the time to join us thank you
I want to talk to you about what's
happened in Nepal um you'll see that
there was a plane crash
um yesterday in Nepal um all of those on
board are thought to have perished what
on Earth could have happened the black
box has been found it will take some
time to decide for that Aviation
consultant Alistair rosenshine is with
us hi Alistair what a tragedy what do
you make of what happened
well as you say a terrible tragedy
exceeds certain accidents always are
um look what we have at the moment is
has been reported that the cockpit voice
recording the flight status report have
been found so uh they will uh the
authorities investigation will be able
to find out
um pretty soon exactly what happened but
what we do have is video of the aircraft
on the approach and it seems to be
rolling rather rapidly to the left and
that would suggest that the aircraft may
have lost flying speed in other words
what we call an aviation of stall
um it's also not very clear in the video
whether or not the flaps were deployed
which they should should be when it
comes into land
okay so what can we gather from that the
plane was too low
um and it stalled
oh well it's impossible to see um in the
video whether or not the aircraft's too
low
um but the rate of roll uh would
indicate that uh the flying speeds have
been lost it would be um extraordinary
to think that Pilots would have allowed
an aircraft to roll rapidly to the left
like that so whether it's mechanical
failure
um a flight control failure engine
failure or something of that nature uh
one doesn't know but it could equally be
a handling error whereby the aircraft
was allowed to um to become too slow on
the approach why does Nepal have such a
terrible record when it comes to Airline
safety
um 300 people Plus have died since the
year 2000 in the year
well that's uh you're quite right
they've been 27 accidents in the last 30
years but uh Nepal is an area of very
very high mountains and rapidly changing
weather so many accidents are due to uh
to that combination of factors you're
doing an approaching to a small airport
with high ground in in poor weather and
uh there's a number of these accidents
have involved actually hitting uh the
ground early what we call a controlled
flight into terrain a seafood accident
um others have involved departing the
runway again because of very poor
weather conditions in in that area but
the uh The Nepalese airlines are in fact
banned from entering the EU air space at
the moment uh simply because the safety
record is so poor
wow goodness me okay it's always good to
talk to you Alice so thank you for
taking the time to join us this morning
thank you
thank you very much